so just to say next speaker is david
mitchell
and if there is one thing to say that uh
david's paper that was already mentioned
several times today on easy hard
easy was one of the earlier papers and
then
um david have done beautiful work both
on propositional side and constrained
program inside
um oh thanks
take the floor okay uh thanks for uh
the invitation uh and the introduction
and uh
thanks um pj and laurent for uh
for setting up lots of things for me so
i don't have to explain many things
i'm going to talk about attempts to
exploit instance structure in cdl ceo
solvers
[Music]
so if we go uh back to uh prehistory of
south solving
uh basically everybody agreed that
reduction to that couldn't be a
practical
problem-solving method uh and and
practitioners and algorithms researchers
both said this and the arguments were
basically
uh all of the form these are hard
problems there's no way you can solve
them without taking the
structure of the problems or the
instances into account
um and uh curiously i think actually
uh the history of south stalwars since
then has has been a proof that they're
wrong
uh but anyway i'll uh so a little bit
less long ago the word structure
was everywhere you went the people were
talking about sap
right so random instances were hard
because they had no structure
industrial instances were easy relative
to their
size uh because they have some kind of
nice structure
and uh sorry i'm just getting my pointer
up here
and and uh crafted instances are hard
because they have this
regular structure so no messy edges that
that
you know algorithms could chew on uh but
at some point
my my feeling was that the the word
structure actually almost became a dirty
word because
everyone would be invoking it all the
time
but nobody could justify it nobody could
say what the heck they meant
when they said it's because of the
structure between then and now
a whole bunch of things that have
happened right so uh
applied stat solving has become a
success story
uh it's clear that real instances
have all kinds of visible structure
laura showed you some visualizations
that illustrate that by
various ways we see that
there's a number of uh
structural measures that have identified
that that correlate
with various aspects of solver behavior
either run time or the choices
b sids makes or the clauses that are
learned etc
okay we have a rich theory of structure
based
fixed parameter tractable algorithms
okay and the best solvers
that we've had during all these times
have never
used structure okay so what i mean so
i've been
messing around with sat solvers on and
off since 1989
so in that 32 years i don't believe it's
ever been the case
that the dominant solvers have had any
mechanism
for making use of instant structure
you mean even explicit mechanism
explicit so
yeah so of course uh it's almost
autologous that they use
uh implicit structure because what the
heck else are they doing if they're not
somehow exploiting the structure that's
there
but beyond that even if you want to make
an argument
that they're using implicit structure
that they're using
it it's really tough i think even with
all the experiments that uh
long carlos and various other people
have have
done there's there's nothing there that
could that really
convinces you it's using structural
properties right it's really tough
okay so so let me just uh again people
have different notions of structure
um so uh
this is pretty much no and i'm talking
about you know global or macroscopic
structure
and usually we we associate this
structure of a set of clauses
with the structure of some graph okay
and here uh
i'm mostly be talking about what's
called the primal graph or the variable
incidence graph
where vertices are
atoms and we have uh an edge between
two atoms if they co-occur in a clause
okay uh regardless of
sign so we have a not p or an s here and
we have an edge between
p and s in this graph okay now there's
lots of other graphs are possible if
you're a theoretician you probably spend
a lot more time thinking about the
incidence graph
which i think is more interesting uh and
occasionally even uh people might
look at the directed instance graph uh
leuron had a different name for it but
but that's where you put the directions
uh
on these edges it completely it
completely describes the
the instance right uh the problem in
practice
is uh the incidence graph is a lot
larger
than the primal graph typically
and and it's also harder to think about
and i think for that reason
uh not all but a large majority of
kind of experimental work has has used
the primal graph
okay if we want to make use of a
structure in our solver
before we can even find out if it works
we need at least three things right so
we need
a property that somehow is related to
solver behavior
this property needs to be computed fast
enough
that that you can get information about
it
uh fast enough to to use in a sat sport
okay and uh then you need a way to
exploit it within
cdcl algorithm each one of these things
is really tough
uh so you've already heard as you know
we've been we've been doing this
for i've been doing it for 32 years
uh and and almost
every reasonable candidate that's been
showing up has already been discussed in
the previous two talks
okay so in all those times there's not
that many great candidates
okay most of these properties are hard
to compute
uh so typically takes you longer to
compute them on on large instances than
it does to run the sat solver
okay uh and and it's very hard to find
ways to make use of them
inside cdcl so i'm going to talk just a
bit
briefly about a few here centrality
community structure and tree with
you've heard about them all most people
in this community already knew about
them all
and let me just emphasize i'm talking
about industrial type cdcl sat solvers
uh if you look at if you're doing maxsat
or sharpstat or if you're doing solvers
for random formulas
a lot of things are different but i'm
just going to focus on
on those okay so centrality
uh comes from the idea well so you
we might want to focus on important
variables and important variables maybe
are
those with a lot of uh
near neighbors a large d neighborhood
for some d or something like that
or so central nodes
okay and we have uh experimental result
and some of it's been
been referred to showing that vcent has
a preference
for central variables okay so uh
but when i see it as a preference i mean
it chooses those kinds of variables a
lot more often than others
for just as your decision variable right
so uh
first likes high degree variables that's
shown in
new shimano a few years ago uh high
eigenvalue centrality variables lauren
just uh
mentioned that and uh high between the
centrality
variables okay has a high preference for
for all of these things uh that's with
uh my student uh sima jamali
okay and also we have that uh uh
learned learned clause variables are
more central than
constant false variables again from uh
cancer relations
okay so when you so this looks promising
okay so uh competing centralities at
least between essentialities is
is times all pairs shortest pass but
that's too expensive for big forms
so we can do some rough approximations
and what we see is that
well in a lot of cases the time taken is
way too much
to think about using this in a sound
solver
in the other cases you can do it fast
okay uh next community structure so
so uh we may uh
like the idea that we can partition our
set of variables in such a way that
uh very few edges occur between
the uh the blocks of the partition and
most occur within
okay and so there's a particular measure
but we don't need to get into it
uh and so we may call a one of these
blocks community and uh variable that
occurs
on an edge between communities that we
call a bridge variable
and we can kind of look at this with a
community graph where nodes correspond
to communities
the size of the node in the typical
pictures the size of the community and
the
thickness of an edge is the number of
edges between those two communities
okay and of course uh one of the things
you like about this
is that uh if you take all the bridge
variables that's a separator for the
graph
okay so we know uh again there's a
number of connections between
uh community structure and
solving and we know industrial pointers
have a relatively good
community structure structures uh
correlated with solving time or at least
uh community structure
makes a better predictor of solving time
than other things like uh variables
or number of clauses etc
this this i i feel there's two sides to
this
claim uh because on the one hand
uh it's not very much of a claim that
it's better than say a number of
variables because because
uh the number of variables of the number
of clauses tells us so little if i tell
you i have a formula with
a million variables about all you can
tell me about how hard it is to solve is
it's going to take more than a couple of
seconds
right we don't even have a good upper we
don't even have an upper bound that's
worth talking about
okay so so on the other hand uh
we're we're desperate for any kind of
measure that actually does have
reasonable predictive value
okay and so this is very interesting
okay and uh v-sids likes to pick bridge
variables has a preference for bridge
variables more than others
okay that's uh appears in uh yang at all
and
uh and uh was replicated uh um
okay so uh community structure is hard
uh
to communicate precisely hard to find
the uh np hard to find the optimum
partition uh but we can use heuristics
and pretty often something happened to
me there
okay so again sometimes
uh it takes way too long um but in a lot
of cases we can do a reasonable
approximation
uh uh that is we can come up with some
kind of reasonable
uh partition uh fast
here's just uh if people haven't seen
them
um we take these measurements but
sometimes it's
uh you should look at things
okay so some regardless of what the the
q values what the
how it scores by a measure you know some
have a nice structure
like this one uh and uh
some have maybe uh less nice structure
like this and this right these are
community these are these are
i'm not going to tell you which formulas
these are formulas from the you know
probably 2016 benchmark set okay uh the
colors the colors here
are the centrality scores for the nodes
in the in the uh
community graph
okay and finally uh treaty compositions
okay so we have a formula like this this
gives us this graph
and a treaty composition is a tree
uh like say this one okay where
um you can think of it this way uh
each edge from the graph has to appear
in one of the nodes so
so the nodes of the tree will be
collections of vertices each edge has to
appear in a node
so i put i distributed my edges around
this tree
and then it needs the additional
property that if if a variable occurs
in uh two nodes it must occur
in the every node on the path
in between them okay so the largest node
here has uh six vertices that tells me
that the width of this decomposition is
five okay so the tree width is the
minimum width of the tree decomposition
of the graph of the formula
again if your theoretician you're
probably used to using the incidence
graph but
excuse me can i ask a quick question
sure
so when you create these communities and
they are connected by bridges
does it make sense to somehow uh arrange
them
given how big one community is or how
small another community is and which one
would be more important in this case
i think the answer is probably yes in
fact
in fact on my white board i have a
sketch of an algorithm
to use that that's been sitting there
for 10 years
but i'm not aware of work really
really doing anything with that idea um
yeah uh thanks okay
so um okay so treatment is hard to
compute
um but uh
um but if we restrict ourselves to some
bound to tree with then we have very
fast algorithms
well okay so linear time algorithms with
some uh very
large constant in front you know that's
exponentially dependent on
k in practice unfortunately computing
even
weak bounds uh
on the tree width usually uh
takes more time than it takes to run a
sats over on the formula
uh and also the tree with the most uh
bench most industrial type formulas
uh are so large that that the kind of
standard methods you would apply at
least to get these complexity results
uh can't be used now people are of
course working on this to improve things
but
but um it's a tough game okay here's
some 3d compositions
of uh some industrial benchmark formulas
when i first saw these i thought these
are beautiful this has to be good news
um but i can tell you you see in these
in these central branches here with a
long string of
of large nodes
these three nodes have
are they're big so they have uh 600 900
1200 uh variables in them
okay so so you can't even think about
doing standard dynamic programming
uh where you you know you have two to
the 500
work uh in each of these in each of
these nodes
okay just so this this little this
little uh
thing here has hundreds of has hundreds
of nodes in it right
uh that are tiny and these are big
okay so now we want to so but we have
some we have some interesting uh
measures now we'd like to use them in
our solvers so here's some kind of
abstracted
cdcl okay we
we have a clause set input and we start
with an empty assignment
and then as long as either you don't
have the empty clause in your clause set
and the assignment doesn't satisfy the
set of clauses
then we're going to extend our truth
assignment
right now by making decisions and doing
unit propagation
until uh either we satisfy the formula
of the conflict
if there's a conflict we derive a
special kind of clause by resolution
called an assertive clause right and
and this gives us some information that
lets us back jump throw out
some chunk of the partial assignment
okay and then we uh add that clause to
our clause set
okay that we've derived okay and
possibly if it looks like we have too
many clauses in the closet to be to be
efficient
okay so this uh
it looks like we have a lot of room to
mess around here and in some sense we do
but but solvers
and uh laurent has a nicer expression
than this
right actual solvers
uh are implemented in a way that makes
it very hard
to make substantive changes without
breaking them almost everything you
drew that's that's big will break it so
uh there's uh the operations and
the solver are highly interdependent
okay
everything's essentially local uh
implementations
uh have properties carefully designed to
maintain locality and cache behavior etc
uh they're often details that are finely
tuned
and related to each other you can't
there's many places where you can make
small changes
and and nothing big happens um
but there's a lot of a lot of
but it's hard to do too much okay so the
question
is how can we bring global structure to
such a thing
and there's there's not that many ideas
at least in the literature okay so
one is you can add extra clauses okay
uh and or you can tweak the heuristics
so the
the main heuristics in in cvcl solvers
are the decision heuristic
okay the clause deletion heuristic uh
and the restart policy
okay so a couple of examples of of
adding clauses
uh at all uh
about five years ago i now guess uh
came up with this scheme you take your
formula
okay you compute its community structure
now you can often do this but but as i
said not always
okay and then you make formulas that
consist
of the clauses from pairs of adjacent
adjacent pairs of communities
okay and you uh you solve them okay and
then you take the learned clauses and
you
and you give those learned clauses
together with the original formula
okay so they gotta speed up with mini
sab and glucose on
unsatisfiable so that's pretty
interesting
and i think you can you can you can
speculate about
this being related to various uh other
techniques
for uh generating um
a bunch of clauses very a bunch of
conflict learned clauses very fast at
the beginning using very special
techniques at the beginning of a run
okay uh very recently uh vladimir
sped up this is a one of the best uh
parallel or multi-core solvers
uh by uh uh developing a clause sharing
scheme that used
a combination of lbd literal block
distance and small community numbers a
community a number is the number of
different communities that the variables
in the clauses
okay so influencing decisions
i'll spend a little bit more time on
this so
um the vcs decision
is you you keep an activity value for
each variable and you
choose as your next decision or variable
with
the unassigned variable with the largest
activity and you update these activities
uh by an additive bump
every time the variable's used in a in a
learn clause derivation and a
multiplicative decay
to uh to emphasize a recent activity
laurent talked about uh about how strong
that recency
is okay and i've already suggested
that the v6 uh has uh strong preferences
for certain types of variables in fact
uh more than 60 of variables are never
chosen as a decision during an entire
run
of the solver um
but among the 40 that are chosen there's
still a lot of preferences okay so high
degree variables are
preferred over others high centrality
variables
by various measures of centrality
preferred bridge
variables are chosen more and so vsan
has been so good for so long
that people kind of tend to to behave as
if
resid does it it's good but i'm not sure
that's always the case so we can ask if
this is good and can we influence it
and the answer is we can influence it by
a very simple technique we call
preferential bumping
just for some special variables
we're going to make the additive bump a
little bit bigger or maybe a little bit
smaller but we used a little bit
bigger and what happened is uh you can
see well
uh here's the fraction
clause the blue line that glucose
chooses
that are bridge variables and if we
bump the bridge variables a little bit
extra we can increase that fraction
that's the green line and if we bump
them a little bit extra but just at the
beginning
then it goes that's the red line it goes
up and then it gradually
falls down but it continues okay
so there's a subtle change but it
changes the behavior and uh and and we
did in glucose we've got to speed up
this is glucose
and we got a little bit of improvement
by doing this
and maybe it may palestine this this is
the winner from
2016 or 2017. okay we went from this
line
to these lines by doing this kind of
operation
okay uh what about the clause deletion
so uh cdcl solvers need to delete clause
they generate a lot of learned clauses
we can't
keep them all forever because it's just
too many and and unit propagation
gets too slow okay so the typical
deletion strategy is uh
we call it the delete half scheme almost
all solvers use some variant of this and
it's simply periodically you sort
all your learned clauses according to
some clause quality measure
okay and you and you delete the worst
half of them
okay there's some details in there that
i'm ignoring but
that's roughly the idea in glucose uh
q is a literal block distance and that
was uh
um
kind of an exciting discovery at the
time
um maybe lc and this uh
the the clause management strategy is
pretty complex
so learn the clauses go to one of three
places i'm not going to go through the
details
core are small clauses that are
essentially kept forever and
local is clauses with lbd greater than
six
okay and these are treated as uh
probably not
you know possibly not very valuable so
in locals
they use a delete half scheme where the
quality measures
activity clause activity is similar to
vc's
scores for variables so we did a
comparison of
maple lcm just with uh
using for the quality measure activity
or lbd or centrality
okay and we define the centrality of
clauses to just be the mean centrality
of the variables that appear
okay again we're using so we're using uh
between the centrality here
uh which maybe i didn't define so
between the centrality
is is the fraction
of all shortest paths
in the graph in which that variable
appears
with a some kind of normalization
okay so what happened is well this is uh
this is uh the default solver
um and this is the performance of a
solver
with uh using centrality clause
centrality as
um the clause quality measure okay so we
went from 215 being solved to 224
par score went down significantly
so that's nice so that's a big enough
speed up that you get to write a paper
about it
uh but but i'm more i'm more interested
in
understanding why of course we don't
understand why any of these things work
so so let's look just briefly at this
uh scatter plot so you see a whole bunch
of
points just below the line those are the
points where we spent time
trying to compute centralities but we
didn't get centralized values to use
but if i compare if i just ignore things
close to this line like here
okay you'll see that there's very few
points down here
and there's a bunch of points up here so
about 80 of the formulas
got gotta speed up in my experience
that's a bit unusual
so every time you make a change to a
solver you get a few you know you get a
bunch of formulas go faster and a bunch
goes slower and overall nothing really
changes
that's what happens most of the time or
you're breaking
um so to get uh 80 percent of formulas
being sped up
and very few bad cases this to me is
actually
uh is actually interesting
so say just a one more uh bit about
uh this before i finish up
okay so so we like this idea of clause
centrality as a
quality measure and we measured a couple
of other things
well a number of other things but i'll
mention two
so uh vijay and his group introduced
this idea of global learning rate as a
measure
[Music]
how good your decisions are okay so uh
this is the ratio of conflicts the
decisions
right the same as the ratio of learned
clauses to decisions it's almost the
same thing as the ratio of deleted
clauses to decisions over
over a long period and if we look at the
version the standard version of
maple lcm and our and our
centrality-based deletion version the
global learning rate is the same
okay but the deletion version
produces more conflicts per second does
more decisions per second does more
propagations per second but the just
other heuristics are identical right so
so this deletion strategy is letting us
learn
clauses that just make the thing go
faster
okay and the second thing is we look at
the quality of clauses to local
by various measures okay so
uh if we look at the
clause centrality of the clauses in
local unsurprisingly
uh centrality-based deletion
uh
rates highest an activity based deletion
is less successful at keeping central
clauses and lbd
price deletion is even less successful
at keeping central clauses
and this ordering corresponds exactly to
the order of the solving time with the
inverse ordering of the solvent
okay uh whereas the order is
different for uh if you look at lbd or
clause signs
so this um
[Music]
this suggests to us that the centrality
is a lot better than lbd
but it's it's a little bit misleading
right okay because we're taking all the
small lbd clauses and we're storing them
at core t2 forever
forever okay so what are really
suggesting
is that when the lbd is larger than six
it doesn't provide that information
right much information still a really
good measure
okay but clause centrality is something
we think is is uh
really interesting but uh i had an
agenda there which is not just to
convince you that clause centrality is
interesting i'll tell you something else
um
if i if i don't run out of time okay so
no conclusions about some thoughts
uh after spending a lot of time on this
stuff
and having very weak results uh
i'm still i think we can we can improve
cbcl solvers
using properties against instructure
but i don't think we have the right kind
of notions of
instance structure work okay we can make
lots of arguments why
the community structure is not right um
and i can tell you something that's not
in the papers about these centrality
measures is uh
for our preferential bumping we
approximated centralities and what we
found is that
uh when the centrality s when the
centrality approximation
algorithm ran fast it got very useful
information
when it ran slow it didn't get useful
information
even though it still gave information
but worse than this
if we computed exact centralities
they weren't very useful so this
algorithm that approximates centralities
is finding
really useful information but it's not
actual centrality values
okay so there's a mystery property in
there that's useful
and useful in a bunch of ways okay but i
don't know what it is
okay next thing is the methods of of
trying to
get this stuff into cdcl are really weak
they're really
you know i'd almost call it lame uh you
know they're potentially useful but
they're not going to change the earth
uh and so we need to think a lot about
what we can do
to still have this algorithm running
and doing what it does well uh
and somehow get uh other kinds of
information
okay anyone who does this kind of stuff
can tell you that doing meaningful
experiments
uh and this kind of material is really
hard it's really a lot of work
and it takes a long time to find
something interesting
uh and it's made worse by a few things
that you know partly to do with the
competition which is a which is a double
sided coin right the competition has
done a lot of great things
for the community but but
studying these things is made much
harder by the fact that the benchmark
sets are sometimes rapidly changing
one year to the next uh suddenly a
method doesn't work
okay and and then the solvers change
okay and the only way i can publish the
stupid paper is if i can beat last
year's solver on last year's
okay but but but everything changed
right so it's very disheartening now i
like i have to i have to uh you know
like spend three months re-implementing
stuff just to find out if it even still
works and sometimes it doesn't still
work
and it's not because it was bad it's
just because the benchmark selection
changed
and dis and disfavors it right and the
winner from last year was chose because
it was chosen because it happens to
align with last year's benchmark set not
big i'm not suggesting it's a bad solver
it's a really good solver
but which one came first is is a lot of
luck
okay and and uh
and so i'm stuck with that by there's a
bias there
okay that makes it hard to perceive and
additional as as
as laurel was was arguing the solvers
now are very complex and we've actually
done some work
trying to and a few other people have i
think the solvers can be actually
much simpler if our focus was to make
simple good solvers
instead of to make solvers that be last
years
uh and that would maybe uh make it a
little bit easier
to do this kind of work and i think but
i think a lot more of this
experimentation of the sort that lauren
was describing i think a lot more of
that is needed
and as a community we should try to find
ways to encourage it
sorry for my uh
okay thank you so much today this was
great
really really interesting so much cool
stuff
and challenges any questions comments
i uh nina i have a question i have a
comment actually
um i was silent throughout but you know
david class
comments on the difficulty of doing
experiments just reminded me of
something that i think as a community we
should be able to do
uh it's difficult to do you know by one
person or one group
in other fields you know they have data
that they make available over time
they could curate it they make it
available so that we can go
and do study on the data so the way that
we have done these
competitions is every competition is
different
uh there is no uh repeatability etc so
i proposed a few years ago to have uh
some kind of a database
that is kind of uh uh
that collects all of the benchmarks over
you know time all of the solvers that
were used
and what their versions were and what
options they had on them and so on so
forth
and this will grow over time and we can
go
and mine that database we can repeat
experiments to see if we can find
patterns
uh i think this would enrich our
understanding of what's going on
uh much more than the uh yearly
competition
that is meant basically to to show i am
i'm faster than you by
by by you know a nanosecond or i can
solve two more benchmarks than you
and and you know the competition is very
good but it's not
helping us increase our understanding
so i think we have a lot of data but the
data is not
organized in a way that makes it easy to
do any kind of systematic
uh analysis
yeah i think that's right i think there
are a number of things potentially we
can do
um and and
that's one you know lauren was already
pointing out that sometimes a solver
from
from a few years ago that's that's
practically
you know set aside turns out to be very
good on some
some current problems of interest this
has happened actually many times
um and also uh you know
sometimes formulas that were left behind
are still interesting
their families or formulas are still
interesting and uh
well a very very simple thing a very
trivial thing
is a couple of times i said to a student
oh that formula
is looked interesting what sort of
formula is that
and the student is new to the community
right so they try to look up what the
formula
what that formula uh
application comes from and of course
it's not documented because it got
inherited from last year's competition
and inherited from the previous gun
right and they go back eight years and
they still can't find the definition of
performance
sorry uh so so you know we can't even do
that
uh you know how can we have a
you know we need to we need to find a
way to look after this
i see laura had just put in chat you
know links to the solvers and the
benchmarks i'm i'm thinking about
a more centralized repository you know
that is accessible
from anywhere so that we can you know
and i think that's missing we really
need to do that i have colleagues here
who are in chemical engineering who have
that
you know when they're doing uh studies
uh in chemical engineering
we want to be we're computer science we
ought to be able to do that
i think when uh so uh vulgar hoes
uh introdu you know created this uh
satisfyability.org website i think that
was
that was his intention that would do
that uh but but it didn't catch on for
whatever you know whatever reason then
you know we should uh maybe this could
be a polymath project i don't know
just this idea um i know it's a great
idea i think
uh just to add to the voices here and uh
i was looking at the benchmark uh
website that laurence sent
lauren uh i maybe i'm missing something
but i don't see
uh practical problem verification
problems
yeah what no i mean the benchmark
database is is nice now it's almost full
it's not
it's a project i was following from
outside but
this is something between the two so we
have a very
very nice global repository for all the
solvers based on the source
so you have the receipt to build the
servers everything is in this
is github you also have a very nice
database of all the benchmark
so what we need is a database that links
the two yes
say okay and that's it i mean we
already have some nice bricks i think
yeah
yeah but this is great yeah this is a
good start um i have
a question to to david uh first thank
you all right
very interesting presentation i'm
wondering did you
come along across
some structural parameter which is
costly to compute but let's say you have
an oracle you or you don't
count the time it requires to compute it
but when you then give the sub solver
this information
there is a significant speed up
i i think i think the answer is no
um i mean i'm not sure so so
currently i didn't i didn't talk about
methods to try to
use tree width but uh currently i think
even if we have a
nice 3d composition we don't know how to
use it
right i mean we we have you know we have
lots of work on on
algorithms uh to use 3d compositions but
what i mean
is i don't i don't think we know how to
make use of that information
in a cdcil solver as as far as i know
there are a couple of uh there are a
couple of papers
making an effort to do that um
[Music]
my impression is that they're using uh
they're succeeding on fairly special
formulas but it's unclear whether
that's uh just because of those are the
ones they can get
decompositions that are nice for or or
whether
uh you know the the cdcl
speed up just doesn't happen
in other cases i don't know
i know i know of course three bits very
well and
for me it's also not really a surprise
to hear about this
results because tribute is some kind of
too strong of a parameter because you
can even do more counting exact model
counting
when the tribute is small so it's
somehow a waste
to use this tributes machinery
and then you quote unquote only want to
solve such
using so for harder problems i think
also for qef
servers um or there's a three bits based
qr server which is uh
quite interesting a good performance but
of course
model counting i think many of this
space and reasoning
uh network algorithms actually use
tribute so
but for sub it's really um a waste
of uh of power
yeah i think it's i agree it's much it's
much too strong
uh the thing is i i know you have ideas
for replacement and it's really tough to
there's there's you know there's a
wonderful uh
theory generalizing uh
tree width right to bigger classes of
sparse graphs
but but the bigger the bigger the class
you make
uh you know the more the more graphs you
include
but but it doesn't look like it gets
easier right so you know nowhere dense
graphs are wonderful but
like but you have to
you know if you want to talk about uh
what's a nowhere dance what's what's
what's a single graph or a small
you know finite collection of graphs
that correspond to nowhere dense graphs
and
then you have to you have to make
something very concrete which again is
too hard
seems to be uh i mean hard computation
but uh but but hard kind of rigid
right i have no sense of of how you make
something where you can
uh again you know what kind of stopped
edges right
you don't care about some number of
exceptions
to being uh right if you had a treat key
comp against something a lot like a
treaty composition
uh but with a you know a small number of
kind of semi-random edges that maybe not
a tree you would be you know
that would be fine
maybe there's also a problem is all
these concepts
that these theoretical models are
proposed by theoreticians
and the theoretician wants to have a
very um
rigid very elegant definition
and for exceptions of course there's no
place there
whereas the solver can't basically do
anything it wants to do and
exploits here that uh some part is like
horn-like and then exploit some other
things somewhere else
and if there are um many exceptions
for the exceptions here that's just
brute force so um
i think there's also a bit of a clash of
of
um community or of of culture
uh because the theorists look at things
maybe from
the more rigid um point of view
well uh if i may add i think i do agree
with you stefan
there uh if i may add a thought there
um i think one thing is clear that
you know from laurent stock and david's
talk as well
that trying to find exactly the
uh separation between easy and hard is
like impossible
and uh we may have to settle for just
you know it is a sub class of instances
for which we can prove a theorem
and it also happens to be a class of
instances for which cdcl solvers
run fast but it doesn't explain you know
its
efficacy in all settings
and with regard to the point that you
raised about
uh rigidity of definition versus
you know solver can uh work well in
even outside that definition actually
goes to the point that i'm raising which
is
the the the we may only be able to
define
a subclass of instances for which
solvers work and just settle for that
and declare victory and move on
additionally
um the difficulty has been that the
the parameters that theorists have been
working with
we have tested them often and they don't
quite connect with reality so
finding at least one per class set of
parameters or at least one parameter
that
uh works well both in theory and
practice i think
is already a big first step i don't know
if that makes sense but
for example community structure seems to
work well empirically
but there are problems with it from a
theoretical point of view
tree width is a very nice theoretical
parameters but
you know doesn't there have been and
there has been empirical work that shows
it's not
the right parameter
the questions in the chat
questions comments
uh yeah akilah has this question about
monotone formulas
uh i killed the answer to your question
as
we should just try it um and
uh maybe if you send me an email you
know we can
set up a generator that will generate
these formulas and
just give it a try can we please read
out the questions the chat it's not even
clear everybody can see them
sorry about that uh so akil dikshit
asked the question
a question to all three speakers of
today is there any well-known
optimization heuristic that's
especially designed to solve monotone
sat instances faster by monotone i mean
every clause in the formula has
all positive or all negative literals
more generally do you think it's even
possible to exploit the monotonicity
of the formula by a cdcl solver
yeah so so the answer the first part of
your question i think it's just a matter
of trying
and i'm assuming that you mean you have
clauses
where all of the literals are positive
all are negative but there's a mix of
such clauses
i don't know whether monotonous city can
be exploited
you know that sat remains npc for such
formulas
uh stefan please
yeah no sorry it's just a general
observation that
that what in this question is called
mountain formula that
remains np-hard for such formulas and
you can transform relatively easily with
a
local transformation any formula into in
satisfiability equivalent formula with
this property
i see the thing about uh
you know cdcl is is as soon as you start
as soon as you start running you're
generating new clauses those clauses are
not going to be monitored
right right right trivially right
that's true you're not going to be
monotone and so very fast
uh you know you're not you're not
working in a monotone setting anymore so
even if you have an idea of the
special idea it's again it's clear you
could exploit
that in cbcl okay
okay right thank you everybody thank you
so much everybody
thank you to all the speakers know the
participants for
great talks and great questions uh
so so i'm posting a link to
um gather town if you'd like to
go and continue talking there and i
guess
next week we'll we'll kind of continue
talking about
structure or
whatever word you prefer for structure
and uh hopefully we will have even more
discussion there
just sorry for cutting not sure this is
really really interesting but i think
they're like
more than 15 minutes of the time and so
thank you so much everybody this was
fantastic